the epidemic of school shootings in
America has prompted vigorous debate
over how to prevent them proposed
solutions range from limiting the
availability of guns to actually
providing guns to teachers but another
approach tries to detect threats before
they become actions one innovative
company thinks that means actively
scanning social media for warning signs
that may call for intervention Don
Dahler visited one city where the
strategy is being put into practice I
think it changed the entire landscape
for for us in almost every school
district in the state of the Connecticut
in the wake of the Sandy Hook school
shootings Gregg Bollinger says he
started to think about security
differently he is the director for
Public Safety in Bristol Connecticut a
district with 8,000 students about six
years ago when when all the districts
around put things together and got got
district crisis teams we didn't have you
know we didn't have much but we added we
added different tools in our toolbox for
school security upgraded security
cameras and more robust screening for
visitors were two of those tools another
one is social Sentinel a social media
threat alerts service that cost less
than $2 per student it scans public
social media posts for threat indicators
like this one which Bullinger received
on the day we visited a young man
tweeted stress can kill you we then
might pass that on to the crisis team
and say this could this could be a
student you know who's in crisis himself
I have about 33,000 posts a month the
actionable actionable posts are 0.97%
I get five or six a day is it that it
just gives you an extra look and red
flags yes what I learned is that it
we're not invading people are posting
stuff publicly so you're not invading
these kids privacy these are things that
they they're posting socially yeah I've
been here 23
years and I pretty much know most of the
administrators or no amol I don't we
don't have time for that one post that
said I'll kill you was flagged another
alert said in part I gotta kill you all
but the person who posted it was not a
student and the line was a rap lyric my
hangnail is literally going to kill me
or my boyfriend is literally going to
kill me
are lexically very similar Poli Mangan
is a social Sentinel data scientist
sometimes our model is very conservative
sometimes false positives do get sent
through because it is very complicated
but we but we hope to remove some of the
noise if you weren't doing this after
you retired what do you think you'd be
doing I'd be working with schools in
some way shape or form around safety
Gary Margolis a 30 year veteran of law
enforcement and security is the founder
and CEO of social Sentinel he says the
company has hundreds of contracts in
more than 30 states your critics of
course say that you and companies like
yours are just profiting on fear after
all the school shootings and that that
really you haven't stopped anything with
this technology you know it's about
being a part of a layered security
approach much like cameras met a need to
be able to put our balls in places where
they couldn't have human beings all the
time the fact doors you know are locked
and access control systems reasonably
let you keep people out when they
shouldn't get in all of these
technologies addressed a reasonable
concern they mitigated a reasonable risk
and and we're another part of that
layers that's layered strategy the
service scans public posts on Twitter
Instagram asked FM and tumblr among
others social Sentinel would not give us
examples of the several hundreds of
thousands of phrases that can trigger an
alert you do think that that's a crucial
part of safety to keep an eye on what's
being said and posted on social media
challenge we have now is long after the
game is over and the classes you've done
in band practice is over you're
continuing the conversation digitally
and you're doing it almost constantly
they're sharing things there that I
think we have an obligation to be aware
of the business of social media
watchdogs is controversial
two years ago Twitter
Facebook and Instagram stopped providing
user data access to a company called
geofeedia which analyzes posts within a
geographic location that was because the
ACLU found police were using geofeedia
to monitor activists and protesters do
you all do that kind of monitoring of
hashtags we're looking for potential
harm so our systems designed that you
can't input that information you can't
we're not us we're not a search tool
we're not a general search tool where
you can log into our system and throw a
word in there
in fact we are purposely not that for a
number of reasons including we don't
think it's appropriate for you to be
able to throw something that might be
politically charged or potentially
troubling as a search term in and just
search for that that is not what we do
you know you have a couple of saves it
changes how you look at this have you
had a couple snares yeah Greg Bullinger
says he's been able to get intervention
for at least two young adults
threatening self-harm despite its flaws
social Sentinel gives some peace of mind
could something happen yes again yes it
kid I don't want to say how but I know
that what I go home at night that word
we're doing all that we can with what we
have to try and protect the kids try to
see all the signals yeah or as many as
you can right for CBS this morning
Saturday Don Dahler Bristol Connecticut
I think a lot of people are saying
whatever it takes
yeah well that's certainly I mean there
are privacy concerns but as he says if
you get a couple of saves maybe it's
worth it right